Everyone knows style
when they see it,
but sometimes good style
gets overlooked.
Not anymore. It's time for
"I Like Your Style."
-♪ I like your style ♪
♪♪
♪ I like your style ♪
-[ Deep voice ] Hey, menu on
the side of the ice cream truck,
I like your style.
I didn't even know they made
Jell-O Pudding Pops anymore,
but according to that
sun-bleached sticker
between the Bugs Bunny bar
and the pineapple sundae
no one has ever ordered,
looks like today's
throwback Thursday
for my tongue...tasty style.
Hey, seasonal aisle
at the supermarket,
I like your style.
Who wouldn't want to buy
a bathing suit off the rack
that's 10 feet away
from a deli slicer?
You got it all,
by which I mean
the exact same American flag
beach chair
I broke last summer.
Next time I need a boogie board
and a citronella candle
and a metal bucket
with three wicks,
I know right where I'm headed.
Style alert in aisle 3.
♪♪
Hi, roadside
fireworks tents,
I like your style.
Whenever I'm cruising down
the exit ramp
and see a structure usually
occupied by circus clowns,
I say to myself, "Ooh,
time to buy some explosives
from a 17-year-old."
No need for sparklers, though.
'Cause your style
lights up the night.
Hey, gas station DVD rack,
I like your style.
It's like you already know
there's no Wi-Fi up at the lake
the Scrabble set's
missing all the vowels.
I especially love those DVDs
named something like
"The Susan Sarandon Collection"
that comes with
"Thelma & Louise"
and three other movies even
Susan Sarandon's never heard of.
And, hey, no need for a case.
I'll just take those loose discs
in an unmarked paper sleeve,
scratchy style.
Hey, grill warming rack,
I like your style.
You're like a little private
balcony for my hot dog buns.
Or, hey, if my vegan buddy
doesn't want his kabobs
near the steak, that skewer
can post up there
like Evita looking down
on her subjects.
Don't cry for her. There's
plenty of style to go around.
[ Skateboard thuds ]
Hey, GPS device that comes
with the rental car,
I like your style.
You're classic, you know.
'Cause who needs Waze
when you've got
a 2005 edition of Rand McNally
loaded up
and a Home Depot scanner gun?
Some electronics get
smaller and smaller
as time goes by, but not you.
You're just a chunky little
TV/VCR combo
right in the middle
of the windshield,
and you've got
style for miles.
That's all of this week's style.
We'll be right back
with Charlize Theron.
Don't go away.
♪♪